hola que tal buenas noche sergio massa
es una figura perenne de las últimas
décadas de la política argentina comenzó
en un partido liberal de derecha en su
juventud la ucedé luego se pasó al
peronismo desde entonces está en el
peronismo fue el jefe de gabinete de
cristina fernández de kirchner la actual
vicepresidenta cuando ella fue
presidenta y sucedió casualmente en el
cargo al que ahora es el presidente
alberto fernández que también había sido
jefe de gabinete de cristina fernández
de kirchner luego sergio massa siguió
desarrollando su carrera que en un
momento fundó un partido se dentro del
peronismo se independizó si se quiere se
lanzó a la presidencia en 2015 no llegó
quedó tercero pero siempre tuvo estas
aspiraciones de poder unas aspiraciones
de poder que lo colocaron en un lugar
privilegiado dentro de la colisión del
gobierno del frente de todos hoy que hoy
por ahora se ve en su cabeza alberto
fernández pero en la que tiene muchísimo
poder la ex ex presidente de actual
vicepresidenta cristina fernández y
también mucho poder
sergio massa que hasta ahora por ahora
hasta la semana que viene cuando termine
de definir esa situación el presidente
de la cámara de diputados y ahora
entrará s el ministerio por estos
movimientos que ha tenido históricamente
sergio massa cercanías y alejamientos
algunos en la sociedad argentina lo ven
como una figura cambiante que cambia de
posición y de alianzas pero a la vez es
un hombre que dialoga con todos y que
tiene muchos vínculos en la política con
empresarios con factores de poder en el
país y hay una expectativa en ese
sentido de que tal vez con eso pueda
conseguir generar expectativas positivas
y tranquilizar un poco la muy muy
convulsionada economía de la argentina